[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
care West and today I bring you the
femme fatale of the Thundercats
Cheetara sideshows 1/5 line of the
Thundercats now you may remember in past
episodes I brought you lion-o I brought
you Umbra well this is those in that
line as well
this is chitara now I thought they would
do a couple other statutes I thought
they would do Panthro necks or on my
favorite character from the Thundercats
are Tygra but they went with chitara and
which is which only makes sense because
when I purchased my he-man statues I
purchase a he-man and Skeletor they
released the Shiro now this is what I
was new to collecting statues and I
didn't purchase the Shuar and I know I
should've purchased her she looked great
and and also they had a evil and I
didn't want the evil and I didn't think
they evil and look great at all but I
should have got the Shiro sold out
immediately and I was left in the lurch
and also waiting they also have an awful
in that line of he-man and I should have
got that statue I'm looking for that
statue as well so if you have uncle hit
me up if you want to sell them um so she
popped up on the pre-order and that was
like over a year and a half ago i
believe and i pre-ordered her so she was
finished she was paid for a while ago
and they decided to release her now and
I am so happy they decided to release
her now she is a fantastic statue but
I'm getting a little head of my
let's go back to why even like the
character
well Thundercats was one of my favorite
TV shows when I was growing up going to
school and I would race home to get home
to watch the Thundercats and she was the
only adult female character on the team
because you had Wiley cattle Wiley kid
one of the you know one of them is a
young female and you know she have the
speed and the bo staff so automatically
you would think that her powers is she
can run like the flash
unlike the flash and I'm like
Quicksilver for Marvel she has a finite
amount of speed that she can use at any
given time it's not unlimited like other
speedsters so and I found that out with
the trials of lion-o one of my favorite
uh six part episodes of Thundercats
there was a continuous line Lionel in
order to be worthy of holding the sword
of omens he had to go up against every
member of the Thundercats and when he
had to race Cheetara
you know his face is like what I'm a
racehorse she's the fastest person here
no not at all she can rich she can speed
and short bursts like a real cheetah and
he and we wind up winning that race with
her because he outsmarted her in a sense
but her weapons is she's an exceptional
bull staff user and her bow staff has
mystical powers she also has a little
bit of psionic powers they didn't really
dabble too much in it and I saw it in
one episode where she used it against
Monroe but it's more like a defense
mechanism but on the bo staff it can
extend all the way out and it can
contract so it's a real good weapon
she's on par with Donatello
as you see Donatello up there she's on
Paul we're down to tell as far as the bo
staff goes so
let's get into the statute I think
sideshow captures the speed and beauty
of the character she's not robust of
voluptuously wise she is sleek like a
cheetah
she is fast looking she is agile and
graceful and I believe that they
captured all of that with this statue
the level of design that they used on
the small details like the feet and the
hands they do show through the head
portrait is exceptional in the sense
that it looks exactly like how I am met
reimagining from the cartoon when I want
to see our face I like the little
special touch that they did in the head
sculpt there is the battery for the
light-up eyes there's a light-up
eye feature on the statue and the hair
comes off of the statue the battery is
located in the back and you put the hair
back on suppers folk it's a beautiful
that's a very smart design and I don't
know this is the first one that uses
that type of design but I think it was
necessary because she has such long hair
and it's a very nice statue well this is
the part of the video when I'm gonna
tell you to write follow subscribe and
also hit that joy button hit that joy
button oh man
that joint button is right there you can
be part of the realm I'm part of iron
Lords podcast you can see a Sundays at
1:00 p.m. and also part of Lords of
gaming dotnet where you go there you can
see more of this statute like the
dimensions the the sculptor and a lot of
host of other informational things that
you will get at the website there's also
a ton of writers a ton of opinion pieces
we have mods gaming where he just
released a new video talking about the
Playstations Unreal 5 engine demo that
was
and I'm telling you he does a great job
and going into detail on what that
engine can do so please go to Lords of
gaming net where you can see a ton of
stuff videos and get a chance to see
more about the Lords well I can't wait
to next week I have a package coming
today and that package is something that
I've been waiting for for a while since
I got my juggernaut this is going to be
epic next week it's going to be colossal
state collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]